bon avant pour commence cette fin de
série sur l'île d'avron j'arrive pas à
croire qu'on soit allé au bout mais tu
ce qui nous a pris nous nous apprêtons à
faire six épisodes
dans la même vidéo sachant que c'est le
même nombre d'épisodes qu'on a fait en
deux vidéos donc voilà un maximum de
force et de courage à clément qui va
monter la vidéo ajouter toutes les
petites voix je t'aime tellement mais
avec la dernière fois je sais même plus
ce qui s'était passé
voici les enfants disparus revenez
jamais et on avait rencontré une autre
femme qui apparemment une histoire il
bruno mais bon c'est pas parce qu on
rencontre quelqu'un qui a le droit
d'avoir une histoire avant que l'on
rencontre un épisode 7 portées disparues
j'ai su prêts au pire mais attends mec
je vais devoir acheter des tickets en
plus puisqu'on doit faire six épisodes
des boutiques les batteurs je me fais 40
kouadja que j'achetais des robes adibal
virtuel les robes
[Musique]
j'adore j'adore les enfants disparus
j'ai tout fait j'ai complètement oublié
moi j'étais poser la chose non pas par
l'amafi des douze bêtes c'est la faute
de droz you ou alors assumer la faute
car vous n'étiez pas là
droz you mais qu on peut pas
faire confiance on te confie les gosses
c'est comme ça je ferai tout l'été
désolé mais on en est quand même la
troisième
alors ça sert à rien d'être désolé
répartis dans la favela à un raid
solitaire sauvé les mecs tu as un
problème
rodrigo aussi linda le dit waouh c'est
la seule façon c'est le seul lieu où mon
corps est une grosse cette affaire arrêt
de faire ces départs dans la famille on
sait comment là vous êtes avec rodrigo
empêcher rodrigo de retourner dans la
favela
moi je vous avoue une nouvelle petite
épopée dans la favela je suis avec toi
au trio aller mais je dois probablement
venir avec toi reste ici au cas où les
enfants arrivent je prends de radio avec
moi tu as mais les chiens c'est chiant
les gens qui font les hérauts comme ça
tu n'es pas un héros rodrigo tué médecin
donc ouais super héros du coup c'est
allé vite par an devrait reprendre aux
you avec toi je sais pas c'est une bonne
idée lui est devenu fou voilà pourquoi
c'est une table ronde où on a besoin de
toi ok je le ferai je n'avais pas trop
le joueur je ne peux pas baisser les
bras
waouh il a sorti la chemise
quelque chose ne va pas les enfants ont
disparu
comment c'est possible droz you c'est
possible parce que droz youth ou d
envoyer des gars pour les trouver
elle envoie une petite équipe là bruno
tu connais merci tu as été un très bon
soutien pour moi malgré le fait qu'on se
connaît à peine
bon on peut par angers ça aussi je
laisse de moins en moins jeune homme
confie à vous attend me dit bon mec le
plein c'est vraiment ils vont se la
couler douce mais ils ont tellement
raison ça va pas les dos de ses enfants
ou n'a rien demandé nous tombe dessus a
nié n'y a pas ce que tu as is on était
mignon innocent doit t d est pas non je
m'excuse en plus j'ai quelque chose
d'important à te dire oh tu veux
produire mon prochain album et me
donnait que 20% des recettes car tu
erres label dangereux
[Musique]
désolé je suis en retard vis vraiment
arrivé en retard
j'ai tout oublié dès que je t'ai vu
entrer voilà exactement bien ça mes yeux
un effort sur les expressions du visage
après si lyon offrir un contrat pour
faire partie du yart godard parce que ça
fait plaisir on s'y attendait pas un
contrat pendant l oued jalouse aulas
pour mais mais une pensée pour
johanna sur twitter #cannes à la seconde
est alors de yann godard on verra cela
non johanna l'atla non la joie n'a ça
s'appelle la jalousie est horrible il
faut payer pour accepter mais nous on
est riche on accepte on la met le we
fall et youtube monnaie dans les
abruzzes je suis flatté je n'arrive pas
à y croire
je voudrais prendre un peu de temps
avant de le signer voilà c'est bien ça
c'est bien c'est business ou vanessa
brown prend tout le temps dont l'ue a
besoin et alstom et le cash melanson
[Musique]
oh vous avez vu derrière ont espionné
taire leurs journaux
oh ça prend maintenant de me dites pas
que non content en saura plus dans le
prochain épisode à les épisodes but le
retour c'est parti je me régale
[Musique]
ouah
si t'as pas d'hélicoptère tequila n'ont
pas tous merci pour tout vraiment j'ai
pas mal de choses à penser après cette
journée aux enfants peut-être peut-être
les enfants priorité si je te propose un
rendez vous galant
bon c'est pas mal je suis ok donc
imaginer que maintenant soit le rendez
vous cannois est carrément tout de suite
les enfants il n'existe plus elle les a
sortis de sa vie en deux secondes mais
qu'est donc il manquerait quelque chose
à ce rendez vous un moment spécial au où
on va le faire attendre encore un peu à
trop facile là parce que tu es un
hélicoptère qui me fait faire des
balades hectares en jeu tous mes
problèmes je m'étais embrassés mais
con tout
[Musique]
je dois
hélico il faut qu'on voie les causes
très important
[Musique]
waouh
mais tout s'accélère mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe linda qui se passe à malaise
cynthia milton arrivé juste à temps pour
fêter ça je viens de proposer galina
rencontre avec le garde ghada excellent
linda plus focus te plaît plus faux cul
en corse de blaye ah ouais les gars
entrer vraiment votre enquête sert à
rien vous êtes vus
de nouveaux parisy frère tu sais bien
que ce n'est pas bon qu'on ouvre à ton
semblait non maintenant qu'ils sont à
côté c'est les mêmes amis souffrir joue
je crois me l'a dit frère la sauvegarde
jumeaux c'est logique je t'ai bien dit
qu'il me semblait connaître tort allons
nous enfin audio
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh le retour des bosses et rodrigo
cynthia newton est aujourd'hui
rodrigo juninho les enfants vont bien
oui mais on les a retrouvés t'inquiète
ils vont bien on a peur dans la favela
il connaît tout le monde là bas aie aie
aie revoit ses embrouilles la caisse qui
se baissent oui je lui ai envoyé
chercher des informations là bas plus
que cherchait il paraissait plutôt
donner des ordres
ay ay ay ay ay le bis de bruno dévoiler
au grand jour y compris à l'êta les deux
hommes totalement confrontation alpha
est ce que qui est le plus alpha
attention linda on peut se parler à un
moment cela seul à le tête à tête qui
proposait tout de suite par rodrigo plus
tard allait d'acquire opus arthur pouces
faut pas oublier qu'elle a emballé bruno
1 face à son bel hélico binda c'est
vraiment important et rodrigo qui force
un qui pousse lac est pas loin du
harcèlement
ok on peut insister sur le fait que ce
pas le moment où alors on peut écouter
ce qu'ils ont à nous dire ce que je vous
ai pas dit c'est que depuis le début de
l'aventuré en vrille secrètement j'ai un
petit crash sur rodrigo c'est faux on te
coûte pas cette chaux
da on va falloir des explications je
fais 0 rires je vous préviens je vais
être très très dur ils votent oui nous
qu'est ce qu'il y a nous avons des
informations sur les enfants dont les
enfants sont entrés dans la favela
ils vont bien bon ben ok cool merci pour
ces news à tout c'est bien c'est bien
c'est la prise de conscience émanant
suspect
oh
un homme et on est en pleine love story
bruno laissez-nous les jaloux les
régions vous entend pas cassé vous tu te
sens mieux bah ouais j'ai signé tu vas
faire de moi une star évidemment je me
sens mieux
tout devient normal on dirait au monde
le passé de meetic non quand anges elle
en train de préparer un petit coup tu as
réserver la voiture pour aller la
chercher demain midi oui elle passe la
prendre à midi elle va nous montrer la
vérité tout avait migré la vérité elle
est en train de réparer un plan non elle
en train de préparer le jeu devienne fou
c'est sûr
[Musique]
je ne sais pas quoi porter pour aller
voir bruno ok ok quels sont tes options
bas il y en a 3 gratuite et une payante
et bizarrement j'ai besoin que tu vas me
rediriger vers la payante cynthia je
trouve bon bah je pense à l'aise
dépenses hacker roquois où là il est où
bruno là ce que j'ai vu là bas est
vraiment différent de sa version bêta ne
peut pas m'écouter et ballets cela c'est
son problème retourne soigner des gens
évitent la meilleure vie rodrigo mais
j'ai reconnu le type qui m'a séquestrée
parlé avec lui tu sais quoi
on devrait parler directement à bruno et
en finir là ok octogone octogone
j'achète une place au premier rang waouh
moi je connais bien ce resto est noté
4/5 stéphane bédard je ne peux pas te
quitter des yeux ronds je veux quelqu'un
qui fait un best-of des belles phrases
de l'aude des meilleures phrases kitsch
de bruno s'il vous plaît c'est vrai je
ne peux pas m'en empêcher ou les
éblouissantes
merci je sais bien gps 5 euros c'est
pour qu'ils me disent que je ressemble à
une grosse merde ça fait chier 20
c'est pour moi un aussi beau et unique
il ya une liste d'attenté de plusieurs
semaines celle le rend pas meilleur mon
pote
ici je veux pas exhiber un aimant je
suis acheté un trophée il est horrible
je le msi mais je ne suis pas une
décoration à mal à le dire ça c'est vous
dire non ce soir une lumière qu'il ferme
là tu t'accroches de branches là dans sa
chute mais on voit ton vrai visage
on s'est quittés et moi je sais encore
plus parce que j'avais la même coupe de
cheveux que toi il ya trois ans
seulement brune
j'espère aussi de voir plus souvent
organisateurs merci pour l'invitation
j'adore passer du temps il ya un cada
aussi bisous c'est le bisou au clair de
lune là excusez moi monsieur
mais monsieur milton est là avec un
autre homme les autres justice c'est que
ça doit être important désolé mais nous
allons devoir interrompre ou une autre
idée aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens dans
tes a même lâché l1 mais ça ça m'énerve
les mecs genre accompagne la ste plait
merci
aie aie aie aie sa deuxième
confrontation là c'est chaud allez là sa
remontée mange ça manque des gros
avant-bras la faune y va donc été là bas
si ma demande je sais que tu fais
confiance à ses employés mais rodrigo
dit vrai il a vu son amoureux avec thor
je n'ai aucune raison de mentir
ce n'est pas le moment mais lui a
peut-être vu autre chose tu dis vrai
engagement du coup a été d'être poli
d'un jeu là la fin la fausse politesse
je pense que ça pourrait être plus clair
si tu enquête
bruno massa soit bruno il n'est pas au
courant ouais mes fesses je le voudrais
mais je doute fort devant trouver
quelque chose faite
[Musique]
mais ce que tu pas comme ça je voulais
te parler il prend enfin le temps de
discuter avec noir ouais je devrais pas
il tenait à être venus voir bruno
comment tu sais que nous sommes venus à
l'est il va faire une crise elle aussi
il va péter un câble je dis la vérité
j'étais la vérité chez honnêtement on
l'a acheté un rencard c'est quoi un
problème on est en coupe nom alors je
fais ce que je veux je suis à dépenser
vous trouvez vachement on peut encore
aller au young gods à celle qui est à
penser c'est le guet-apens c'est le plan
de johanna
non c'est ça ils ont fait un petit dîner
en tête à tête je connais ses empreintes
de lèvres c'est cette joie
[Musique]
hu
ouah non mais je devienne fou là je
devienne fou épisode 10 trahison waouh
soient fiers joie n'a franchement pas
bons trios ce n'est pas ce que je pense
aucune phrase ne veut autant dire le
contraire de son sens primaire que celle
ci aucune au monde ligne je ne veux pas
savoir
ça me met mal à l'aise j'ai juste mal à
l'aise mais qd il te plait on en parle a
pris est calme on savoir de quoi ni de
yann cada a lâché désolé d'un terreau
moi je suis l'avocat du lieu du lieu où
vous voulez vraiment inea content vous
devez chanter ici tous les soirs là dans
la prochaine année avec un sable contrat
il est incassable
si le peuple et oies donc depuis le
début c'était rodrigo l'amour de notre
vie
[Musique]
finalement pu nommer kevin sont pareils
mayaleh mais attendez mais y'avait pas
un troisième homme dans cette histoire
c'est pour tricot il est temps de
rentrer à brooklyn
tu pourras pas que tu exagères va pâtir
cela
alors on en est ou de thor 2.0 là enfin
le tort de la favela revoilà lui
exactement
oui j'ai parlé avec aux sabots et
maintenant on nous suspecte bruno
rodrigo est devenu un vrai risque
tu avais pensé à quoi ceux-ci se
résoudre à très vite ils vont buter
rodrigues mais c'est quoi ce bordel là
mais qu'est ce qui se passe là reviendra
comme une fleur de hockey j'ai peut-être
fait une erreur mais tu vas pas profiter
de ma faiblesse sentimentale pour me
pécho ok mon pote donc tu veux repartir
a conclu line je devais bien y retourner
un jour tu ne peux pas partir juste à
cause de ça je suis sa cause de ça tu
l'as vécu c'est toi qui as vécu ça ou
c'est moi excusez moi j'ai un doute est
ce qu on se souvient de passer avec
rodrigo bah ouais ouais se souvient on
se souvient en 71 tirs nous aussi je
suis venu te chercher l'été où tu es
rentré de riom linda je pensais qu'on
était passé à autre chose
alors du coup ci c'est en tout cas mais
avec des tocards pital in data zéro
chance mais c'était fini entre nous il a
fait quoi attend lui aussi m'a trompé ça
l'histoire c'est quoi encore ce bordel
la dernière chose que j'imaginais te
trouver avec une autre caisse et bien ça
d'accord et ce qui est un mec qui trompe
pas dans ce jeu tu sais que je n'ai
jamais voulu te faire de mal je ne sais
pas si je pourrai avoir de nouveau
confiance en toi je ferai tout pour
en espérant que tu puisses me pardonner
et bien lourd sur cette fois à ça ils
sont partis quand les acculant je te
propose qu'on se voit demain à 10h au
pain de sucre en civil da je t'attendrai
hockey
[Musique]
je n'arrive pas à croire que je m'en
aille demain est-ce qui va m'attraper
juste avant que je monte dans l'avion
exactement comme ce qui s'est passé avec
kevin le scénario se reproduit mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait là lui linda
pourquoi écrit li na en espagnol
mannheimer point d'exclamation à
l'envers au début le conte est devenu
espagnol entre-temps qu'est ce qu'il
fait et moi aussi je devais d'espagnol
loi des partis voir tu forces top attend
nous ton papa je ne veux pas parler avec
toi bruno au wild est vraiment vénère
c'est beau j'ai besoin de te parler de
quelque chose d'important
[Musique]
ce qui se passait
mais je devienne fou
non mais attendez attendez depuis le
début au paso c'est ce trou du cul qui
vit bordel de merde épisode 11 mai à
l'avant dernier épisode on cherche une
réponse c'est parti
[Musique]
non
quelles sont les nouvelles c'est bon ils
les ont tout a fonctionné normalement
pas fait plus de charge de la suite
c'est quoi la suite à ta faute
ça devient narcose en fait là ce n'est
plus du tout une histoire d'amour autant
de tricot il me fait de la peine causée
aux linda est avec toi comment ça pas
avec toi montre audio je suis là au pain
de sucre comme convenu mais pas elle
elle était trop distraite en se
promenant non dans les rues de ne pas
paniquer je sais mais peut-être que
linda est en danger mais pas que c
ronaldo qui va sauver bruno serait fou à
laisser partir rodrigo tu va enfin faire
quelque chose de bien c'est tout moment
aux bigots de briller tout est en or les
invités sont installés pour une fois tu
fais quelque chose de bien topo gratuit
quoi comment rodrigo peut-il être en
train d'envoyer un message je viens de
comprendre on lâche coup il ya des trucs
j'ai pas compris dans un jeu destiné aux
la remise en question elle va être dur
après cette vidéo hills avec linda avait
un regard ironique vous qui pensez
choper linda et rodrigo sauf qu'en fait
trop d'ego n'était pas encore arrivé et
c'est bruno qui est venu et du coup ils
ont chopé les dames bruno sans faire
exprès les cons
quelle bande de cons
oups mais tu es stupide ou quoi non non
un peu la tête en l'air bon ça arrive de
spa g bref c'est comme ça que oui merci
que tout ce que je fais baudet tu vas
payer pour être mais les deux ce qui ne
te regarde pas attention ce sont bruno
au nom de quoi
non mais attendez c'est pas grave parce
qu'il nous reste le dernier épisode dans
laquelle nous allons apprendre toute la
vérité après c'est fini il n'a rien à
tout jamais c'est parti comment est-ce
que ça va finir
[Musique]
sur la l'entrée dans sa peau c'est
maintenant je sens que ça pour la cades
jeu sans regarder ce que j'ai trouvé au
sommet pas les chiots s'il vous plaît
toi tu n'as pas le seul à me dire ce que
je dois faire
n3b that ont fait roger mais vu que
c'était la grosse victime la du groupe
de mafieux donc tu la fermes
ok qu'est ce que tu vas faire tes mains
sont attachés ouais moi c'est un
argument comme un autre gros rodrigo est
en chemin elle le met dans la merde
à quoi sert rodrigo je suis désolé à
cause de toi linda a été mise en danger
ce sont des employés les coupables de ce
désastre il a l'art de gounod bator le
moment de se disputer pour ça il y
occupe ce choix je sais pas mais je suis
au pif à ses torts et sur bruno jetable
est prévenu de ne pas lui faire
confiance
écoute moi bien rodrigo je sais quel
homme gentil et que lui les méchants
mais problème si je t'aime pas je ne
ressens rien pour toi physiquement alors
tu me laisses tranquille je suis
amoureux d'un conte c'est la vie tu me
fous la paix maintenant
je m'excuse d'intérêts entre cet appel
le disque mais dis moi qui est de sa
faute mais il n'étend pas les faire une
petite balade
il a ramené son ex policier magnifique
j'ai toujours dit que c'était un bon
gars lui j'ai dit non mais c'est vrai
quoi quoi
[Musique]
du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça va monsieur
bruno alors dante était gentil ou
méchant mais on est perdu on a
émoustillé de suite à cette visite n'est
jamais pouvoir tu devais rester fidèle
dans tes
une semaine après il est temps de
quitter rio ce n'est pas un bon moment à
passer
vous pensez à autre chose a maintenu de
voyage par exemple attendre ils veulent
me faire payer jusqu'à la fin quoi
jusqu'à fin vous voulez me soutirer des
sous j'ai pu et dû linda j'ai pu
l'argent tu comprends ça tu te mets en
confortable et tu fais pas chier
maintenant voilà maintenant que tout
s'est passé c'est l'heure de reprendre
ma vie tu est la bienvenue quand il
voudra amis je retournerai
je vous promets elle retournera vous en
faites pas le retournera non vraiment
non obligés et rodrigo bruno qui
m'attrape le bras je le savais pas si
j'avais sa coupe de cheveux avant je
savais qu est ce que tu fais ici
et attention rodrigo je ne fais pas
permettre que tout se termine comme ça
entre nous non mais pas trop d'ego je te
propose quelque chose je compte amener à
new york dans mon avion privé en profite
voyage nous parler réfléchir 12 heures
de vol avec toi mais pas du tout c'est
pas du tout rythme avec lui ne pardonne
pas surtout laisse là bas et je reviens
salariaux des bonnes moi une chance s'il
te plaît li na no
c'est vrai comme ce soit une vraie
conversation non je voudrais adapté de
venir goûter bagages sur une api timide
rigaux s'te plaît c'est moi ainsi linda
oui je vais pas te laisser partir comme
ça hu
j'ai le sentiment qu'on se soit une
chance une fois parti je ne sais pas
rodrigo on a le temps il ne s'est pas
passé rien ne s'est pas passé alors
c'est sh-awd rigaud c'est qu'on a tout
fait ce qu'il fallait peut-être voir
encore plus de temps faisant du temps tu
veut fabriquer du temps au frigo tu te
contrôler plus dans des mensonges était
pas possible de fabriquer du temps
voyons eu de rester avec moi à vélo au
moins une semaine
faire rigoler ce que tu fais ici la même
chose que toi je suppose je demande à
l'instar de rester demander ça je lui ai
proposé de l'emmener à new york
bref j'ai avec moi j'ai un jet privé
attaquois toi waouh quel choix est-ce
qu'on avec bruno ce qu'on valait que
rodrigo bah désolé on tricote un jet
privé toi allez bruno le jeu de briser g
avec toi bruno au nom ça me fut bon
voyage linda c'est ciao
aude jusqu'à l'aéroport
je n'arrête pas de penser à thouars foot
est connue comme la demoiselle en
détresse et j'ai connu d'avoir sauvé
mais et doit façonner de marie paule et
sans passion
j'ai plus qu'un binôme avec un
hélicoptère ch et surtout vu un
hélicoptère
[Musique]
c'est trop ça me dégoûte vous me
dégoûtez bon on a fait tous les pires
choix c'était comme dans nos vies
personnelles ce qui s'est passé on a
fait tous les pires choix écoutez on a
fini la saison une j'espère cette petite
aventure de trois vidéos vous aura fait
marrer c'était vraiment drôle
en fait je pensais pas ouvrir trois
vidéos là dessus c'est aller loin cette
histoire vous l'avez amener loin de
trucs quand on se sera bien marrer
c'était rigolo le temps de trois vidéos
je ne ferai pas à la suite mais rien ne
vous empêche d'y jouer de faire que les
choix pape et c'est gratuit si vous avez
envie de connaître la suite qui dure 21
une saison enfin bref c'est comme je le
pensais avoir c'est sacrément con c'est
sacrément cliché après même temps ça
respire pas ça se veut pas être un grand
visual novel du tout donc bon bref j'ai
quand même passé trois merveilleuses
vidéo avec vous là dessus c'était
vraiment marrant et puis voilà at de la
prochaine qui n'aura rien à voir avec ça
peut-être activités manuelles noront
continue la pause
il faut qu'on se ressaisisse allez à
bientôt et merci tout le monde c'était
grave rigolo et dérangeant
[Musique]